I don't have to tell you how tough it is
to get a Nintendo switch right now but
it's not just the console itself that's
selling well I'm Tony and this is your
record-setting GameSpot news update
Mario Kart 8 deluxe sold four hundred
and fifty nine thousand copies on launch
day in the United States across both
physical and digital Nintendo says that
makes it the fastest selling debut in
Mario Kart history the record was
previously held by Mario Kart Wii which
sold about 20,000 fewer copies on day
one considering this is essentially a
port of a Wii U title those numbers are
impressive of course zelda breath of the
wild is also a record holding game in
terms of launch sales so I guess I
shouldn't be too surprised either way
make sure you hit that subscribe button
to keep up on all the hottest switch
games Mario Kart 8 deluxe received a 9
out of 10 from GameSpot so consider that
a solid endorsement if you haven't made
up your mind about picking it up and if
you'd rather see it in action first you
can check out the live stream archive of
our epic interoffice tournament
[Music]